We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. here's
a very important question about non voters
non-voters take a listen to this.
Hey David.
I was wondering with all the democratic candidates
outright now if your personal candidate doesn't
get picked, is there a certain number of people
that will just refuse to vote for the Democrats
because their candidate isn't the nominee
or is everyone just going to vote for the
Democrat?
Does that hurt?
There was a lot of issues last year where
there were a lot of people who were Bernie
supporters who were smirk that you didn't
get abomination and decided not to vote for
Hillary Clinton.
So listen, I don't know the answer to that,
but it's something I am afraid of and we,
it is so important right now that we take
step one in starting to repair this country
and it is only step one, which is the removal
of Donald Trump.
Earlier on today's program and on other programs,
I've talked extensively about the damage done
by Trump will extend far beyond his presidency.
The Republican party isn't fixed when Trump
leaves because the Republican party is what
allowed from to become their nominee and ultimately
to become the president.
So when Trump leaves the Republican party,
it's still an absolutely abortive attempt
at being a reasonable political party.
So we need to remove Trump is step one and
unfortunately it is conceivable that if someone
really likes one candidate and that candidate
is not the nominee, that some of them will
stay home or some might vote for Trump.
Although I hope it's a very small number as
close to zero as possible.
Some may go third party, some may write in.
I think that that's extremely problematic.
Now if, if you're in a truly safe state, I
understand that your calculation may be different.
Strictly speaking, I think that the right
way to approach this is assume the election
could be close no matter where you're voting.
I get that in Massachusetts, the Democrat
is going to defeat Donald Trump, and so if
I vote third party or write someone in or
don't vote, it's not going to make a difference.
But the problem with that logic is if everyone
who has that thought occur to them takes the
action, that does change things.
So I think it's logically fallacious to fall
into that lack of thinking.
We should all just vote as if the election
did depend on our vote in terms of whether
people might just stay home because their
candidate isn't there.
My hope is that people who don't like Donald
Trump would realize that any of the democratic
options right now is better than Trump and
that thus they would vote.
So I could understand people who are in the
Bernie Warren wing, if Joe Biden is the nominee
saying, I'm not voting for Biden.
Biden says, we covered today that a, you know,
marijuana is a gateway drug.
Biden's not for serious reform to the health
insurance system.
I'm not going to vote for him what Trump is
worse.
And I think at this point we have seen that
the let Trump win to break it all down and
then we'll rebuild it mentality.
I mean, it just hasn't worked.
It did, it didn't play out.
It's not surprising that it didn't play out
that way.
I think that is very dangerous thinking.
So we'll have time to talk more about this.
I do believe that we need to start seriously,
uh, talking about the reality that everybody
should participate if turnout favors them.
They win easily.
Even with low Trump approval because of the
electoral college system that we have, particularly
if our sides turn out as depressed in those
key swing and battleground States.
So I am very worried about it.
I don't want to be hyperbolic or alarmist,
but mathematically in those States where it's
close, uh, some Democrats saying, I'm not
voting because my guy or gal is not.
The nominee could turn some States for Trump.
And it could turn the election for Trump.
We don't want to let that happen and we'll
talk about it more.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about a cheating allegations
against the Houston Astros that have the baseball
world demanding punishment and we're going
to talk about cheating in sports more generally.
MIT's AI scores the egotism of drivers to
try to make atonomous vehicles more assertive
if they assess that drivers around them are
driving in a particular way.
It's very interesting and it relates to some
of the complex math that goes into programming
autonomous vehicles.
And number three, we've talked about the Starbucks
open bathroom policy in the context of a race
based discrimination that we've seen at some
Starbucks stores in the last couple of years.
There have been some stories about that.
There's a very interesting new study that
says that on the one hand, the open bathroom
policy does some good things for Starbucks.
On the other hand that it seems to be hurting
foot traffic.
And, uh, as many of you know, I've not been
to a Starbucks for 15 years, so hopefully
producer Pat will be able to inform me on
exactly what it is that is going on at Starbucks
these days.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, become a member@joinpacmandotcomtogetinstantaccessorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show at the $5 or greater
level that will also give you access to the
boat, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].